you have to be functionally [ __ ] to
believe that this guy not only to
believe that you can get free college
but that this walking Muppet who was
washed on hot is the guy to do it are
you kidding me here's something that
raised my cackles Bernie Sanders now
here's something that's important with
Bernie Sanders people often who disagree
with them we saw this a lot they would
say you know I disagree Bernie Sanders
but he seems like a good guy good guy
and I used to think that I saw the three
house I thought it too the three houses
and I saw you look at some of his
investments you look at the way he's
lived his life he's a little
hypocritical but then you watch a clip
like this and you see that Bernie
Sanders isn't it yeah until he hears
something you realize it tells what
someone he disagrees with and then you
then he's a dick
it sounds like a social justice warrior
can evil guess who character she's like
an evil guess who character as you're a
person balding Oh Gus Go Fish
I don't know what guess who is I don't
know what that guess who term is I know
you put down the little cards here's the
thing about Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders you realize when you watch this
he's an ass and it's only because you
never see him in forms with people who
disagree with him think about that for a
second you always sort of thought Bernie
Sanders was unlike Hillary Clinton he
wanted to discuss a difference of ideas
and his ideas were bad he very very very
rarely went on forums where he would
express those ideas how often did you
see him on Fox News how often to hear
Bernie Sanders in a more often do you
hear him giving press releases or give
granting interviews to conservative
websites never so it's really easy to
seem nice well that train came to an end
when he was at a town hall here last
night I love this he was confronted by a
small business owner and to those you
out there on YouTube who are mad that we
trash Bernie trigger warning my question
is this
I'm a business owner and we just keep
getting kicked in the teeth by this
administration it's regulation after
regulation and tax upon tax what Donald
Trump does understand is the
complexities of business and you know to
reward the person who takes the risk so
really you know my question is this
country was founded on
entrepreneurship why is this
administration so against the business
owner please tell me I don't think this
administration the Obama administration
you're referring to is so against the
business owns Obama did I don't know
your income and I'm not concerned about
your income pause okay I don't know your
income and I'm not concerned about
nobody is more obsessed with income
personal income or a corporate income
than Bernie Sanders it is all he cares
about
it's what his campaign was about it's
what his signs were about as a matter of
fact how much do you want to bet he is
so obsessed with your personal income
that the next statements out of his
mouth down to the decimal are going to
be about your personal income over/under
roll clip let's see Obama did raise
taxes on the column excuse me he raised
taxes on the top one or two percent of
all new income generated day goes to the
top one percent ah but he doesn't care
about the income right I don't care
about your income unless you're making
one percent unless you're making one
percent it by the way weird let's it's
important we just find this people think
1% people think 2% where are you and if
you're in the one-percent united states
top 1% is at three hundred and six
thousand dollars joint household income
if you make that you're in the top 1%
top 2% is a hundred and ninety two
thousand dollars joint household income
okay you've seen us do this and joint
household income is important to join
household pounds come come is very
important now it's a good living but in
New York LA San Diego San Francisco
you're not rolling in the Benjamins so
it's important he's talking when he
talks about the top one I think they've
done too well the top one and two
percent in the United States it's
important to keep that in in the context
let's roll the next clip because it's
relevant to this point when you think
about 90 percent you don't think that's
obviously too hot no but I think is
obscene and it frightens me this again
when you have the top one-tenth of 1%
owning almost as much wealth as the
bottom ninety does anybody think that
that is the kind of a con
this country I don't care about your
personal income this is the top 1% of
the 2% if we're texting 90% because the
top 2% I make a modal bottom 20% but I
don't know he got percentage points I'm
fighting for the people ok so he's
saying he didn't think it's unreasonable
attacks top 1 or 2% at 90% $192,000
joint household income you're being
taxed at 90%
that doesn't sound unreasonable to you
that sound like the People's Revolution
you have several people on your block I
don't care where you live in the United
States who are in that income bracket
this is why it matters he's sitting down
with a small business owner and by and
by the way he sidesteps the question he
always sidesteps the question you'll see
let's go to his next clip you'll see
what I'm talking about so you and I may
have a difference but yeah I do believe
that billionaires and multimillionaires
should be paying more in tax I'm a
business owner I'm not a
multimillionaire
I'm not a billionaire ok so there you go
right about do we've another one of him
talking about that yeah ok let's roll
the next clip and then we'll hustle
through this okay hey I mean you haven't
lived until you put a payroll on your
credit card you know I mean this is the
reality of the backbone of this country
well the backbone of this country I
think we should support
entrepreneurialship I think we should
support small business but wait but when
it ever burns but I am NOT supportive of
large multinational corporations that
make billions a year in profit and don't
pay a nickel in taxes nor am I
supportive of those corporations who
throw American workers out on the street
and then move to China automate what
about this this is the brilliant sleight
of hand that he does right top one or
two percent we've established that's
$192,000 1% about $300,000 you top 1 or
2% he's talking to a small business
owner who was likely top 1 or 2%
especially if you understand how LLC's
work they act as pass-through entities a
lot of people are taxed at individual
income rates a lot of people are making
that much in growth they're not making
that much and that many people who you
know who run small businesses most small
businesses if there are 10 million
dollar business you think they're a
giant business they're not they would be
taxed at those margins perhaps 90% which
wouldn't be outside the realm of reason
for Bernie Sanders but he sidesteps the
question he's being asked by a small
business owner about taxes so I don't
know your personal income level I don't
care so it sounds like gee golly Bernie
Sanders is he's so good he doesn't even
want to attack this guy personal then he
immediately proceeds to attack the guy
personally by talking about people who
vinas income bracket but what he does is
he sidesteps it here's a business owner
in front of him asking him a question
about me a small business owner what you
want to do that negatively affects me
but the both be billiard in both be
billion-dollar corporations and what
does that do it makes you think that the
top one or two percent is coca-cola it
makes you think that it's only the koch
brothers
it doesn't make you realize that the
small business down the street running a
Rite Aid or running a Taco Bell
franchisee falls in that top one or two
percent so automatically Bernie Sanders
vilifies the wealthy vilifies of
business creators by the way people who
have to he's this guy had a brilliant
point you haven't lived until you've had
to put payroll on a credit card a lot of
small businesses who would be in the top
1% have to borrow money to make payroll
so they can get inventory for the next
year the same people you want to pay
your employees 15 bucks an hour yes
those same people doesn't want to pay
those ones putting up the payroll on
their credit card right so he's
vilifying the people who go out and take
the risk and he says you know what the
the 50% of this of the willth have been
put in the top one or two but why do you
think 50% of the wealth created has gone
to the top one or 2% they're the ones
who are out there taking risk they're
creating businesses they're employing
people they create jobs why is that a
bad thing don't get so hung up on the
percentages especially if you don't know
what it means good a guy makes a
household who went out who used their
savings they bet it all on black
themselves like this company we employ
10 people we would be the top one or two
percent absolutely Jared Jordan Edward
Scott Lacey Francine Courtney Casey
Brautigan were top one percenters and no
one's getting rich but we would be taxed
at that rate we rolled the dice I bet it
on myself and guess what I'm able to
employ people so 50% of that wealth went
to be able to make payroll for these
people and I didn't pay myself a dime
for several years Jared can testify to
that
he was in my old piece-of-crap house
with broadcast out of it
let's go the next clip China Ottoman
talk about the small business I think we
should support is do you think there's
space to work with Trump on that he's
talked to Lila
getting out of regulations but you can't
say in Jeff what does I mean should that
small business or a large business be
able to pollute the water or the air or
the food no small bit what about the
what about this man here who's asking a
legitimate question motored burly
multi-billion dollar corporations
what about what about the fact that this
guy has to take out credit to make
payroll multi-million dollar
conglomerates what about the vet that
he's talking here would you support
small businesses sure but what about air
pollution poisoning food sources the guy
is so full of crap he is so full of [ __ ]
and you people have bought it because he
brought you have to be functionally
[ __ ] to believe that this guy not
only to believe that you can get free
college but that this walking Muppet who
was washed on hot is the guy to do it
are you kidding me
Bernie Sanders don't know what it's like
to pay anybody because he couch surfed
like a Burlington loser until he was
forty something and he suckled at the
government came out as three houses
including a lake home that's why Bernie
Sanders can't relate to it
these are the people writing the
legislation let's roll the final clip
really because this is important there I
don't pollute water I don't pull it food
however when these rules and regulations
come in to cover all of business and
you're starting trying to start a
business it's tough enough in the gym I
think we should take a look at it but
it's you know the devil is in the
details we got to see what those
regulations are some of them by the way
may not all okay that now sudden the
Devils in the details which we don't
fully understand really you just went
through percentage points as to who you
could vilify and who you would text 90
percent and whose stuff you would take
and exactly how much they make and the
problem of the multibillion-dollar
corporations the problem with a
multi-million dollar corporation is the
air pollution all of a sudden it's okay
well what would you do to help small
businesses you do the lip service which
is what the left does I of course want
to help small businesses how are the
doubles and the details what details oh
that's what happens and they hope that
you don't pay attention what details the
guy goes on ask him regulatory costs
regulatory burdens what would you want
to know the regulatory burdens are here
I have this right on table right here in
front of me ten thousand dollars per
employee for any business with fewer
than 19 employees that's 1.75 trillion
dollars in 2008 alone in regulatory
burden so if you're employing 18 people
15 people you're paying $10,000
out-of-pocket just to cut through the
red tape Bernie Sanders before he goes
on his diatribe which is entirely anti
business and won't function in the real
world says oh of course I want to
support small business really how that
doubles in the details give me details
well some regulations what regulations
have you ever in your life Bernie
Sanders or your ilk found a regulation
found red tape this is personal because
I run a business and these people their
lives depend on it a lot of credit comes
less mukluks join or your bernie sanders
supporting asshat these regulations are
stifling the small businesses it's why
they're leaving statewide they're
leaving states like California New York
for states like Texas or states like
Nevada ironically enough with harry and
larry reid who got the crap beaten out
of them in the shower because it's
business friendly so bernie you want to
talk about helping small business helped
to name me one time that you found
something you found this $10,000 cost
per employee in a business and you
cut it me me one we know how you would
like to tax the wealthy the top 1% our
top 2% hundred ninety two thousand a
household income at ninety percent but
when it comes to how would you help
small businesses the Devils in the
details
how come you never give details son
you